[Musique]
comment vous dormez vous avez un lit ou
bien vous dormez en impesanteur hébert
et non ondes en impesanteur on a un sac
de couchage qui est accroché au mur on
flotte et tu t'endors un peu en flottant
que les gens qui flottent les bras qui
flottent et la première fois c'est un
peu bizarre parce que quand tu te
réveilles le premier matin tu as tes
bras ils vont ils se mettre en position
un peu comme ça de repos c'est la
position naturelle des articulations et
quand tu te réveilles tu as des mains en
face de toi tu dis waouh qu'est ce qui
se passe est en fait c'était propre main
voilà après tu t'habitues au début ça
fait un peu bizarre
sans couleur sans quoi ça coco
est-ce que tu as conscience que tu es le
sdf les plus classes de france mon gars
là je te jure t le f il se fout de ta
gueule ben il crie de chute mais les
cultes
or là ils ont pas le même code
[Musique]
mon